you see the 20-year-old life coach they
don't have a lot of credibility cuz they
haven't lived that much life even if
their stuff's amazing but if they talk
about the struggles that they have
experienced and gone through and only
talk about their story and talk about
people they have helped not what you
should do in general for everyone but
talk what they have done for the few
people they have done it for no one can
question that here's Sarah Sarah
overcame her anxiety issue and here's
how we tackled it no one can question
that no one's going to attack you for
that but if they find Value in it then
they might follow you and what happens
is over time you do that enough you
might grow big enough that then you can
start taking a side step and go a little
bit broader it's like across all the
people that I've worked with this is
what I found again I'm just going a
little bit broader but again no one can
question me cuz I'm talking about what
I've done not about someone should do